okay well yeah that's a bounce-back
[Music]
broadchurch episode number six now
absolute number five I did not like at
all so I actually I mean I'm releasing
these videos back to back to back day
after day but in terms of recording I
took a two weeks I think since I watched
episode five before sitting down to
watch episode six cuz I just I didn't
wanna I just I really really disliked
episode five so much but this was good
actually episode six might be the best
episode of the show so far because well
it opened well you know the first few
episodes were largely taken up with
establishing everything establishing the
characters the dynamics the town etc etc
this feels like the first episode since
everything's been established that
really just digs into the meat of things
and and it all feels relevant nothing
feels like a distraction nothing feels
superfluous it's like all this means
something and it feels like these are
actually moving forward and also there's
a lot there are character moments but
they ring true in a way that the
relationship crap from the previous
episode just didn't so we've got things
picking up with after the death of Jack
played by David Bradley the the
newsagent
so we're coming off the back of that and
you know dealing with the fact that you
know the town had kind of turned on him
when there was no evidence point towards
him and then you've got Pete I think his
name that you've got the vicar
but the problem is I see Arthur Darvill
I want to say Rory that's that's my
problem that's why I stumble over that
anyways so you've got the vicar I would
say rightfully calling out the town and
the cops saying you not only did these
people time you didn't protect him I
told you he was in danger by everything
that was going on and you did nothing
and he's not wrong
yet at the same time I think that
there's a certain justification in David
Tennant in the way that he responds in
the way that he holds his ground like he
still has a job to do and he can't be
worried about people's feelings he's not
gonna get the job done otherwise and
we've had we finally I I knew it was
coming I like I'm surprised the show
took this long to pull the trigger on it
but I knew it was coming that eventually
we were gonna get you know the hint fed
what if the religious guy is messing
with kids and we've had our hint at that
I'll I don't know if it's gonna go
anywhere I kind of would prefer it not
because that's a that's a little skeevy
I I don't particularly want to deal with
it wouldn't necessarily or it could
depending on how it's done it wouldn't
automatically be a fault or a nosedive
for the show if it went that way just on
a personal level I don't it doesn't and
in a lot of ways that that feels like
the cheap shock thing you know it seems
like the easy way to do it you know to
get a real visceral reaction out of
people and I'd like the show to be
better than that more creative than that
but really sort of hinting at that and
it doesn't just end up being a hinting
being you know just another layer of
paranoia another laying on both for the
cops and for the audience of you're
suspecting everybody even when it's the
flimsiest thing you could possibly be
latching onto that's what I hope that
actually is because that because that
would
fit that would fit very well so I don't
know what's going on with this woman the
moment the dog Susan Susan right yeah I
don't I mean I got a bad vibe from her
from the beginning I don't know if I
mentioned her in previous reviews but
yeah I had a weird vibe from her from
the beginning and Tom this there's that
moment with him at the funeral when
Danny's sister says you know yeah you
were Danny's best friend he goes why
does everyone keep saying that I hated
him and I am genuinely curious to find
out what's behind that and that I cannot
remember this guy's name at all I don't
know I don't know the actor but the bald
guy who works with Mark and you know
then show it which I appreciate but
pretty sure he killed the dog so whether
he was involved in the death of Danny or
not he can you know get locked away for
the rest of eternity
I am totally fine with that I am down
for it yeah but look everything just
kind of clicked in this it had a sense
of tension that felt natural the
investigation is actually ramping up
there and there's there's the moment
there's the scene between Beth and the
and the mother of the the dead girls
that that David Tennant's character
couldn't close the case on before and
that that scene is really sad as it
should be and you feel the weight of
this other woman's loss and Beth just
trying desperately to find anything any
indication that she can continue a life
after this and then there's the scene of
the Latimer's at the arcade and
seeing them play and laugh and be a
family and yet the music always keeping
that sadder tone and never letting you
forget probably much like they
themselves even in a moment like this
probably can't forget that the world
still kind of broken and everything
still sucks so that that was a really
that was a really well done
juxtaposition because there was nothing
there was anything held back in the
performances and it you know they looked
like they were have it they were family
having the most fun possible and I think
that was a that was a nice gesture of
Mark because you know after they they
found their daughter basically hanging
out with a boyfriend in what was you
know kind of a safe space a space for
her to not be the sister of a dead kid
that you know that Mark and tries to
offer her a way to do that but that
doesn't I slayed her from her parents
and that it works and or you know for
the day for the day it works and Beth
gets to benefit from that too and it was
a nice moment but also like I said the
music not letting you relax with it
because you know you shouldn't be left
to feel oh these will be okay because
they probably won't but for the moment
they can be alright and so that was
really good yeah and like I said the the
way things are layering I really want to
know what's going on with Tom she was
smashing the laptop and you know if if
the Vicker doesn't report Tom smashing
that laptop to the cops they better have
a good justification for him not doing
that if he doesn't do that yeah
something's going on in and he should
recognize that so I think that's about
it I think that's all the stuff I wanted
to hit it was on the the female reporter
again she really is awful
she's the war
and I'm glad that was Oliver the the
local reporter has now realized that
she's the worst you know took a little
too long to do it but you found out I
could have told her that in five seconds
but you realize gay fine so yeah this
was good this was really good and it was
such a quick bounce back that I really
am hoping that Episode five is gonna end
up being that isolated one episode that
just happened to have all these little
things that I just don't like pour it
into it so it just becomes the bandages
off it was that one episode it was
flying up to that it'll be good after
that so that's that's fingers crossed
I've got two more episodes to go I'm not
intending to tackle series two or three
broadchurch it is my intention to only
do series one so yeah two more episodes
to go and then I will let you folks know
having taken in something that is very
much you know the creation and headed by
Chris Chibnall whether or not that
impacts any of my thoughts on him as
Doctor Who showrunner so we'll see
so that'll do it for this one episode
six of series one of broadchurch what
were your thoughts on or whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff that you can do like support me on
patreon little as a buck a month hey it
helps and you can follow me on Twitter
listen to podcast etc etc etc links for
all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]